Muller time is over now it's time to pay
the bar tab Attorney General William bar
has appointed a US attorney to
investigate the origins of the Trump
Russia investigation and any potential
wrongdoing on the part of Democrats or
federal government officials we
investigate the investigation of the
investigation then democratic
congresswoman Rasheeda Talib rewrites
history while referring to the calming
Holocaust because nothing says calming
quite like the Holocaust finally Joe
Biden dominates the 20/20 field as bado
tries to reboot before it's too late
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
time to pay the bar tab I am going to
find any excuse I can to recite that pun
and that meme that is my favorite meme
of the last year when all those muller
time t-shirts that were being sold are
now being sold for about 75 cents in the
used clearance bin on amazon it's all
over now we are in the era of william
bar and this investigation just got more
interesting people aren't paying a lot
of attention to it right now because
everyone's so happy that the Muller
report is over it exonerated the
President on collusion but this is where
the real investigation begins and we're
gonna see where that's leading but first
we're never going to agree on everything
are we you and I might but in the whole
country we're not going to the one thing
we can all agree on so we could use more
sleep getting a great night's sleep is
easier and more affordable than you
think you don't need a new expensive
mattress or sleeping pills you just need
to change your sheets that's why you
should check out Boland branch this is a
very true story I woke up today it's I
don't know six o'clock or something I
said I'm gonna I'll snooze my alarm so I
thought I snoozed my alarm I didn't I
woke up about an hour and a half later
cuz sweet little laces Mac Mac you got
to go do a show but I just felt so comfy
on my bowling branch sheets sorry you
can't blame me for it can you from
bedding to blankets everything bowling
branch makes is made from pure 100%
organic cotton which means they start
out super soft they get softer over time
you buy directly from them so it you're
basically paying wholesale prices
instead of paying a thousand bucks for
really nice sheets like you wouldn't a
department store you're buying the same
quality for only a couple hundred bucks
from Boland branch shipping is free you
can try them for 30 nights you're gonna
feel like you're staying at the fanciest
hotel you ever stayed at that is that's
my favorite part of it is I'm in my
little apartment but I feel like I'm
staying at a five-star hotel if you
don't love them send it back for a
refund you won't want to send the back
though no risk no reason to not to give
them a try to get started right now my
listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets that's a lot of money
Boland branch calm promo code Michel mi
CH AE L go to Boleyn branch calm today
fifty bucks off your first set of sheets
vol L and branch calm promo code Michael
mi CH AE L Boland branch calm promo code
Michael time to pay the bar tab
have you asked yourself this wire
Democrats right now going so hard after
Attorney General William bar remember
they went after Jeff Sessions he's a
hack he's a trump act then they went
after Matthew Whitaker who was in in the
attorney general position after sessions
briefly interim and then now they're
going after William Bar William Bar has
a sterling track record William Bar was
the Attorney General thirty years ago
under George HW Bush you know the first
Bush the Bush that all the Democrats are
pretending that they really like now
because he just died remember that but
he was the Attorney General for that guy
very well-respected but now they're
pushing very hard against him and the
reason for it
is that William bar is threatening to
expose Democrat wrongdoing during the
Obama administration specifically with
the opening of the Trump Russia
investigation William bar has been
signaling this for a little while now
and the more he signaled it the harder
Democrats are going after him we saw the
preview here during those hearings that
Barr had on with the Senate Judiciary
Committee here here's where he promised
that he was going to get to the bottom
of this Trump Rush investigation do you
share my concerns about the FISA warrant
process yes
do you share my concerns about the
counterintelligence investigation how
was opened and why it was opened yes you
share my concerns that the professional
lack of professionalism and the Clinton
email investigations something we should
all look at yes you can't see it on
camera here but but and you can't even
hear it I guess the microphones weren't
turned on but there are Democrat heads
exploding when Attorney General Barr was
saying this because all of a sudden
we're no longer talking about the Muller
investigation we're no longer talking
about Trump collusion or Trump
obstruction or the thing that Donald
Trump did thirty five years ago or
whatever now we're talking about how did
this investigation start how did the
Obama administration start spying on the
Trump campaign why did they do it what
was going on who acted wrongly and
who acted in a criminal manner finally
we're gonna get to the bottom of that
Attorney General bar has appointed a US
Attorney to examine the origins of that
investigation the attorney is charged to
see if the investigation was lawful and
appropriate to see if the spying was
lawful and appropriate if this is not a
special counsel but it might as well be
there's practically no real difference
between whether bar had appointed a
special counsel or if you just tasked
this u.s. attorney with it and so it
will the investigation will focus on how
the government collected intelligence on
Trump Russia collusion it'll focus on
the spying it's being led by a guy named
John Durham John Durham is a US attorney
from Connecticut
he has got truly a stellar reputation I
mean I think this is a big part of why
he was appointed he has served as a
special prosecutor investigating
wrongdoing by the national security
officials by the agencies FBI CIA he's
been a DOJ lawyer since the early 80s
and this is the important part he has
conducted investigations under both
parties so in 1999 Attorney General
Janet Reno had him investigate the FBI's
handling of Whitey Bulger Whitey Bulger
the famous Massachusetts mob boss who
was an informant for the FBI
investigated that that was during the
Clinton administration
then during the Bush to administration
in 2008 Attorney General Michael mew
casey had him investigate the CIA's
destruction of torture videos in 2005 as
I was under the bush to administration
then following year under the Obama
administration Attorney General Eric
Holder had him investigate whether the
CIA broke laws regarding the abuse of
detainees so this guy has total
bipartisan credibility now the question
here is why did Barr appoint this US
Attorney to investigate it when we
already have another investigation going
on there are now two investigations of
the investigation going on I know that
sounds confusing but we have the this US
Attorney investigation that just began
we also have the inspector general
investigation into how the Trump Russia
investigation started so we
have the the watchdog for the DOJ is
also investigating this this is Michael
Horowitz and bar says that this report
from the inspector general is going to
be done in May so why have the second
one we know by the way that the
Inspector General report is going pretty
well we know it's already turned up some
dirt on the FBI this I G report but
Michael Horowitz helped to get that
crooked official Andy McCabe fired and
possibly prosecuted for wrongdoing as
specifically for delaying the
investigation during 2016 of the Hillary
Clinton email scandal and the Hillary
emails that turned up on Anthony
Weiner's laptop when he was brought in
for sending weird messages to young
girls see how far deep this goes see how
many layers they are to these
investigations we this is how the
Democrats win this is how the so-called
deep state wins is there are so many
layers to these investigations that most
people just can't keep it straight in
their heads so they say oh I don't know
they're all crooks never mind we'll move
on but this is important you've got the
watchdog at the DOJ looking into all of
this already finding dirt already
finding improper actions possibly
criminal actions taken by these Obama
administration officials with regard to
the 2016 election possibly influencing
the 2016 election you've got him sources
say describing James Comey is
insubordinate you've got him criticizing
Obama's Attorney General Loretta Lynch
for meeting on a tarmac with Bill
Clinton and coming up with some possibly
crooked deal so you've got that going on
with the IG now you have this separate
investigation why two possibilities one
Attorney General bar already knows
what's coming in the inspector general
report the other one is the bar knows
that John Durham this US Attorney is
extremely credible on both sides of the
aisle and what I think it is is both I
think probably I mean look if you and I
already know that the IG report has
turned up dirt on these people obviously
the Attorney General of the United
States already knows that so he might be
getting a lead on the findings of those
of that report and looking a little
further into these guys and the other
one is the Democrats have already gone
on the offensive to tar William bar is
some sort of partisan Trump PAC so
probably they'll go after Michael
Horowitz when that report comes out so
he's saying I'm gonna get a guy who is
so he has such a pristine record the
Democrats cannot possibly try to smear
him as a trump hack and and the thing
with John Durham this US Attorney is the
Democrat senators dick Blumenthal Chris
Murphy have come out in great support of
him they've called him a fierce fair
prosecutor so the minute they tried to
go after this guy for uncovering dirt on
the Obama administration they're just
gonna play all those clips of these
Democrat senators talking about what a
great guy John Durham is I think that's
why we have to investigations the other
one is we want to be very thorough here
broadly speaking we don't want to make
the same mistakes that Democrats did we
don't want the Trump administration to
make the same mistakes the Obama
administration did we don't want
conservatives to make the same mistakes
leftists did this is the main takeaway
here how did Democrats handle the Muller
investigation they put all of their eggs
in that basket
they prattled on for two years three
years about how Trump was a Manchurian
Candidate he was a secret stooge for
Vladimir Putin he's a criminal he's a
traitor then the report turns up nothing
and then they look like a bunch of
idiots we don't want to make that
mistake look already the investigation
into the investigation the investigation
into wrongdoing under the Obama
administration already that has turned
out much more evidence of wrongdoing
then the Muller report into Trump and
collusion did we already knew there was
way more dirt on the hands of Obama
administration officials and Democrats
than there ever was on the Trump
campaign for colluding with Russia we
already know that but we don't want to
over promise and under deliver here
we've got these two guys on the case the
IG
in this US attorney it's a long way
until 2020 there's a lot of time for new
dirt to come out we don't want to
overplay our hand I think in part
William Barr might have been motivated
by that he doesn't want this to become
this awful political mess like you saw
during the 2016 election he doesn't want
to become the next James Comey or the
next Loretta Lynch or the next what he
doesn't need that on his hands so before
the IG report comes out let's say the
let's say the IG report comes out and it
says the Democrats acted totally
improperly the Obama administration was
illegally criminally spying on the Trump
campaign it's all awful at that point
you're gonna have Republican senators
the president and all their GOP
activists calling for a new special
counsel calling for a new investigation
calling for more probes so maybe what
William Barr wants to do is get ahead of
that not for partisan reasons but just
actually to maintain the integrity of
the DOJ to say we're not launching this
new investigation we're not launching
this US attorney investigation because
of pressure from Senate Republicans
we're doing it because that's where the
evidence is leading us I think it's
really sharp I got to tell you I feel
very comfortable with William Barr at
the helm not that I feel ideologically
comfortable like he's going to agree
with conservatives on everything I just
feel this is a guy who's extraordinarily
intelligent he is extraordinarily
experienced and practiced not just in
the ways of Washington not just in the
ways of the DOJ but with the office of
the Attorney General he's already done
the job before I feel finally for maybe
the first time in the Trump
administration I feel that the DOJ is
settling into good hands and so I think
we should let this play out I don't
think we should get too far out ahead of
it it's gonna be very enjoyable as
evidence starts to dribble in of all of
the wrongdoing that the Obama
administration engaged in let it happen
don't let your anxiety get the better of
you patience is a virtue it's going to
be a very enjoyable way to 2020
specifically because the the Democrat
Party is exploding the the whole left
wing is totally falling apart
over in DC over in Congress Rasheeda
Talib a rising star the Democrat Party
has now referred to the Holocaust as a
calming event she is not she not only
said that phrase which is so outrageous
she is rewriting the history of the
Holocaust and the creation of the State
of Israel now this has nothing to do
with investigations of Russia or
collusion or whatever this is just
purely the Democrat Party in the
ideological left collapsing in on itself
and specifically on this issue of Israel
here you see two major leftist
strategies at play if Rasheeda Talib
does them both at the same time she she
does the performance of victimhood and
she does the rewriting of history both
at the same time both central to the
left-wing agenda he or she is speaking
both sides of her mouth about the
Holocaust and there's you know this is a
kind of a calming feeling I always tell
folks when I think of the Holocaust and
the tragedy of Holocaust in the fact
that it was my ancestors Palestinians
who lost their land and some lost their
lives their livelihood the human dignity
their existence in many ways have been
wiped out and some people's passport I
mean just all of it was in the name of
trying to create a safe haven for Jews
post the Holocaust post the tragedy and
horrific persecution of Jews across the
world at that time and I love the fact
that was my ancestors that provided that
right in many ways but they did it in a
way that took their human dignity away
right and it was forced on them so none
of that is true nothing she just said is
true either she's a profoundly stupid
woman or she's lying and I don't think
she's stupid so I think she's lying none
of what she just said is true
first of all just this is just a note of
rhetorical advice when you are
describing the Holocaust it is best to
avoid the word calming it
of all the where many words in the
English language calming is not the best
one to describe the Holocaust
Erick's whoa well the sort of
presidential candidate just did this the
other day when he compared Russian
election interference to September 11th
again another piece of advice it's best
not to compare things to September 11th
you now have two rules for rhetoric
don't compare things to 911 don't refer
to the Holocaust as calming but then she
rewrites history everything she said
that the the Arabs in British mandatory
Palestine they welcomed the Jews and
they said Jews please come in please
establish the State of Israel we like
you so much we want you to be here they
were so as how happy Rashida Talib is
that her ancestors the Arabs in
mandatory Palestine they welcomed except
none of that happened
that did not happen Arabs in British
Palestine did not want the Jews to come
in what is my evidence of this well for
one they allied with Hitler so the
leader of the Palestinian Arab
nationalist movement Haj Amin
al-husseini allied with Hitler he was
living in Germany in Berlin from 1941 to
1945 he not only elide with Hitler he
called for the massacre of Jews in the
Arab world he not only called for the
massacre of Jews in the Arab world he
did it uh Nazi radio stations all
throughout Berlin he called specifically
for an anti Jewish jihad he then aided
the Nazis because he was friends with
Hitler he aided the Nazis in recruiting
Muslims from the Balkans for the SS and
for the ver macht he launched a revolt
the so these are the Palestinian Arabs
they launched a revolt between 1939 and
1936 and 1939 to deter a European Jews
from coming into the region of Palestine
when we when we use the word Palestine
by the way we have to be clear we're not
referring to a country called Palestine
there has never been a nation-state
called Palestine that nation-state might
as well exist between Narnia and Wakanda
it is completely imaginary completely
fictitious
there is a region that was named by the
Romans Palestine so when we referred
historically to Palestine were referring
to a region named by the Romans well
after the the nation of Israel inhabited
that land so there was palace and then
when the British took over the area
there was the Mandate of Palestine it's
referred to British Palestine or
mandatory Palestine so that's a region
not a nation-state so the Arabs who were
living in British mandatory Palestine
launched a revolt to stop Jews from
coming into the area and eventually they
petitioned the British to stop the
refugee Jews almost altogether from
entering the region Rashidah Talib
completely reinvents that history and
here is how that history is being
described by scholars on both sides of
the question supporters of a Palestinian
state supporters of the State of Israel
and this is according to the left wing
Israeli paper Haaretz professor Benny
Morris a scholar of British mandatory
Palestine and the creation of the State
of Israel said quote Rashidah Talib is
either completely ignorant of the
history or is a deliberate liar that's
my reaction entirely and I think
professor Morris is probably a little
too kind to her because I don't think
she's just a total idiot he goes on
though he said Talib x' ancestors quote
did nothing to alleviate the suffering
of the Jews at Nazi hands rather the
opposite the Arabs of British mandatory
Palestine during the whole period and
supported by the neighboring Arab states
did all they could to prevent Jews
trying to escape Nazi hands from
reaching the relatively safe shores of
Palestine that is a Jewish historian an
arab historian dr. adel mana said quote
i don't know what she meant it was
natural that when the palestinians
thought that the danger to their
existence was real they started to
resist the Zionist project fair enough
Israeli historian Thomas Segev quote I
have never heard anybody say that before
I really can't imagine that any
Palestinian shares that noble center
of welcoming all of the Jews into the
area he goes on I really want to give
her the benefit of the doubt that she
really meant it but to me and maybe I'm
cynical
it sounded like an attempt to be ironic
or sarcastic now I don't think she was
being ironic or sarcastic I think she
was lying I don't think she was making a
joke I don't think she was using verbal
irony I think she was lying and and she
was reliant on Americans historical
ignorance and specifically the
historical ignorant of her left-wing
base which is manifest it's obvious that
her base is historically ignorant most
Americans don't know very much about
history most Americans can't name the
three branches of government I mean the
the the ignorance epidemic in this
country is terrifying
one third of of young Americans think
George W Bush killed more people than
Soviet dictator Joseph Stalin you
probably don't believe this because if
you're listening to this show you have
an interest in current events and
history and culture and religion and and
so you you read about these things a lot
the vast majority of this country does
not and it's not exactly their fault
they've been failed in education by
their parents they've been failed in
education by their teachers K through 12
and then through college as well
you can now graduate from Yale with a
degree in English and graduate summa [ __ ]
laude and never have read Shakespeare
this is a profound problem and this is
what the left relies on they rely on
historical ignorance so does when she
gets called out on this does she admit
does she say okay you're right I
misrepresented the history I'm sorry
you're right I lied about it I'm sorry
you caught me you all know the history
and I tried to get one over on you know
because people don't know the history so
instead what she does is she reverts to
the classic leftist strategy of calling
her critics stupid racists the tragedy
of the Holocaust I mean the reason why
Israel was created was create a safe
haven for Jews around the world and
there is something like in many ways
beautiful about that my ancestors many
had died or had to give up their
livelihood their human dignity
to provide a safe haven for for Jews in
our world and that is something I wanted
to recognize and kind of honor in some
sort of way but I also think it's
important because I want Palestinian
people also to find some sort of you
know light in this kind of what's
happening but also you know in the end I
said I want all of us to feel safe all
of us deserve human dignity no matter
our backgrounds no matter ethnicity no
matter even our political opinions we
all nee deserve that kind of equality
and justice and you know for me I wanted
to uplift that and bring that to light
and it was unfortunate you know I a text
message from a friend who's like hey
next time you know really clarify maybe
talk like a fourth fourth grader because
maybe the racist idiots would understand
you better
[Applause]
how're the racist idiots that's maybe
the racist idiots what I see if you
disagree with rashida - leaves complete
rewriting of history the only
explanation is that you're a racist
idiot now ironically what she's relying
on to spread her lies or racist idiots
right she's relying on people who don't
know the history and she's relying on
people who have a sympathy for Arabs a
racial sympathy for Arabs and a racial
antipathy for Jews because if you knew
the history you couldn't possibly agree
with what she said because what she said
he's demonstrably false so what she's
just relying on is a growing problem in
the Democrat Party which is a lot of
Democrats these days don't like Jews
they have an antipathy for Jews and they
have a racial preference for Arabs in
the region this is what these movements
students for justice and Palestine are
which is a one of the most ironically
named groups because it's it's not led
by students it isn't about justice and
there's no such country as Palestine you
could put every part of it in quotes or
the boycott divest and sanction movement
of Israel which is basically to starve
Israel and and stop it from being a
nation-state that that's what she's
relying on ant empathy for Jews
antipathy for Israel and historical
ignorant so how is this playing out lest
you think that I'm only presenting one
side here
I don't think I am I'm presenting Arab
historians Jewish historians her own
words but lest you think I'm only
playing one side let's turn to the
leftists par excellence
the typical leftists on CNN even that
Network even John King on CNN can't
defend what she said yes she said
Palestinians lost land in the creation
of Israel but she ignored the fact that
Palestinian leaders at the time allied
themselves with Hitler and the total war
was how the Arab world reacted to the
declaration of Israeli Independence
simple as that
I mean you've got to give the left some
credit here there is a photo of Arab
leaders from the region of Palestine
sitting face-to-face with Hitler having
a grand old time with Adolf Hitler
himself and then they have the audacity
to go on television and say yes my
ancestors they welcomed the Jews with
open arms they gave they laid down their
lives they laid down their lives to give
the Jews a safe haven either that were
they alive with Hitler and started years
of uprisings and tried to kill all the
Jews it was one of the other I forget
it's one of those two so CNN kudos on
them for at least for for I think 14
seconds exactly reporting the actual
history here how is this playing out at
the elected Democrat level so you got
the media okay there being not fair but
at least briefly presenting the other
side at the elected level the level of
Nancy Pelosi the politicians are
defending Rashidah Talib at that elected
level the the Speaker of the House of
Representatives leader of the Democrat
Party Nancy Pelosi she's defending the
total historical revisionism of Rashidah
Talib she tweeted out quote Republicans
desperate attempts to smear
representative rashida and misrepresent
her comments are outrageous President
Trump and House GOP should apologize to
rep Talib and the American people for
gross misrepresentations in the face of
that inversion of reality in the face of
a lie so egregious is that I lose my
capacity for indignation how am I
supposed to respond to that Rashidah
Talib according to every historian
completely inverted the history of that
region and of that moment she she lied
through her teeth and then Nancy Pelosi
the head of her party calls on all of us
to apologize to her for misrepresenting
history you can't eat you can't even get
upset about that you just sort of sit
back you say huh all right I guess the
Democrats are living in a perfect
fantasy world that has no bearing on
history no bearing on historical text
books or documents or words words lose
their meaning in the face of that sort
of defense
now why is Pelosi doing it and what
effect will this have on 2020 we'll get
to that in a second but first I've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
go to daily wired.com it's ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me you get the Andrew Clayman show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh show you get to ask questions
in the mailbag coming up on Thursday you
get to ask questions backstage you get
another Kingdom you get all this stuff
and you get the leftist ears tumblr this
is very important hmm
oh this is a very delicious the the
leftist ears tumblr serves this
wonderful purpose of just refreshing you
reawakening your mind to real history to
real politics and it's a great delicious
beverage to watch the entire left
collapse go to daily wire.com get it
we'll be right back with a lot more
why is Pelosi defending Rasheeda Talib
why is she defending obvious historical
lies why why is she doing that she's at
doing it because she's having a tough
time keeping this fractious house caucus
together she's also having a tough time
dealing with the growing anti-semitism
on the Left so you remember Ilan Omar
the other Jew hating freshman Democrat
she made all of these comments about how
awful Jews are and they're hypnotizing
the world and they're just buying off
American politicians and you can't trust
them because they have no allegiance to
America she made all these comments and
Pelosi tried her best to keep quiet she
tried the time they were saying Nancy
come on speak out against her and she
said I can't because our party hates the
Jews now so I can't I gotta kind of go
with them you had Democrat congressman
like eliot engel and Nita Lowey
saying we need a resolution to condemn
anti-semitism come on Nancy at least do
that Nancy said oh that's really gonna
upset all of the anti-semites in our
party so they watered down that
resolution made it about all sorts of
hatred a total cave now with Talib she's
defending her there are two major
takeaways here specifically for
Democrats one this is why Democrats hate
history it's why they hate historical
education
it's why they rip down statues it's why
they ripped down murals it's why they
ripped down monuments it's why they
rewrite high school history curricula
it's why they support taking courses out
of historical curricula in college they
hate history because history is an
obstacle to their political program
historical knowledge is an obstacle to
their political program one of the
issues now on the left is way cutting
Israel divesting from Israel and
establishing another Arab state in
Israel that is now a platform that is
endorsed by huge swaths of the left
around the
world and in the United States now there
are many good arguments against this
course of action one the the Arabs in
that area elected Hamas a terrorist
group to be their government too they
elide with Hitler during the Second
World War three they have no historical
claim to the land the Jews do have some
historical claim to the land many what
are the arguments for the establishment
of a new Palestinian nation-state in
parts of Israel Wow Wow
racism idiot racism idiot I don't
whatever smears written no the argument
that Rasheeda Talib is trying to make is
that the Palestinian Arabs welcomed the
Jews in and they were so good and there
was a misunderstanding and then a total
totally made up but the argument for
that agenda is a fictional narrative the
argument that right-wingers tend to make
for their agenda is a historical
narrative the argument that the left
tends to make is a fictional narrative
why should we get rid of male and female
bathrooms why should we have an all
gender or 56 gender bathroom the the the
reason that the right wants to keep
different bathrooms for different sexes
is because there were two sexes men and
women that's a fact that's a biological
fact and a fact of nature
the reason the left wants to get rid of
male and female bathrooms is because of
a fantasy that there is no such thing as
gender or there are 56 genders or
they're 58 genders or whatever they're
saying now the reason that the right
wants to have borders security and wants
to build a physical barrier on our
southern border is that foreign
nationals are not American citizens is
that nations have to have borders
nations have sovereignty nations get to
decide who comes in and out our
immigration law decides who comes in and
out the reason that the left wants open
borders is because they deny even the
historical legitimacy of the
nation-state they deny the reality of
our immigration laws they deny the
atrocities that happen along that
journey they deny the drugs that are
coming in they denied the gangs that are
they have a fantasy that they're pushing
that's the difference that's why we have
to learn history it's it's why it is so
important for right-wingers to learn
history people ask me what they should
major in college major in history if
you're debating between poli-sci and
this and the history history is
important it is the best scholarly tool
that we can use against the left-wing
agenda that's the ideological take away
from this the major political take away
Democrats are now the anti-israel party
you got the Republicans or the
pro-israel party the Democrats are the
anti is real party this is a serious
tension between the old Democrats and
the new Democrats in part because most
American Jews are Democrats so you have
a lot of little older school Democrats
now who are saying gosh I can't be part
of a party that hates Israel that hates
the Jews now
if you've got these more old school
slightly more moderate Democrats you
have these new Democrats like Rasheeda
Talib and Ilhan Omar and Alexandria
Casio Cortes which side is winning out
if 2020 is any indication voters across
the country prefer the old Democrats why
do I know that because Joe Biden is
absolutely killing it in the polls he is
dominating this entire race if the
election were held today there's no
question that he would be the nominee he
might he might be the winner with the
majority of votes in a field of 20
candidates I mean he is he's killing it
that much in the South Carolina field
right now Joe Biden is leading by thirty
one percent of the vote he's not leading
with thirty one percent of the vote he's
actually got 46% of the vote the next
highest candidate is Bernie Sanders who
has 15 so Joe has triple Bernie's
support in South Carolina after Bernie
in South Carolina is Kamala Harris with
10 percent after that you've got Budaj
edge and warren with 8 percent after
that you've got poor cory booker 4%
after that you know there's a name I
haven't said yet it's a name you've
probably forgotten
poor old bait oo Rourke he's some Irish
guy from Texas he's only got 2% these
old Democrats Joe Biden and
even close between Biden and Sanders
triple and poor bado trailing at the
bottom of the pack so what is bado going
to do bado is trying to reboot his
campaign he is leaked this to reporters
he's gonna reboot you're gonna get bado
2.0 he's showing up to events in New
Hampshire and getting crowds of 30
people I mean this is not going well for
him
the reboot is not gonna work
there's no reboot he got the best boot
of in the whole world
he got glossy covers Vanity Fair you
remember that I'm in it I'm in it to win
it and this this should have told us
that he wasn't going to really go
anywhere because whichever candidate
Vanity Fair likes is not going to be the
candidate I remember something campaign
in 2012 I love John Huntsman our
ambassador to Russia I think he's a
tremendous guy Vanity Fair gave him a
great glossy treatment I said no don't
let no vanity fair-- should not do that
because in some ways it's the kiss of
death if the media likes you too much
you're gonna have a harder time on the
campaign trail that happened to bado and
then the main thing that happened to
bado is Budaj because Pete Budaj is in
every single way the better bado or
Rourke in every way he's smarter he's
better educated he's got executive
experience they don't work tab a door
work was just a congressman at least
mayor Pete has been the mayor of a small
town he's Budaj edge had checks off more
boxes on the intersectional victimhood
hierarchy he can say he's gay they're
both privileged wealthy white men but
he's at least gay so he can play that
card in the Democrat primary and most
importantly of all Budaj edge is a
winner in bado is a loser
Budda judge won his races Budaj edge is
the mayor of this small town in Indiana
Beto's a loser we forget he's a loser
because the media treated him as a
winner
the media after he lost a Senate race in
Texas they basically treated him like he
won but he's a loser and you don't get
to lose and then immediately become
president
almost took Texas from Ted Cruz great oh
cool
almost and a buck-50 will get you a cup
of coffee almost means nothing in
politics John Boehner used to make this
point the winners go to Washington and
the losers go home doesn't matter if you
lose by 50% or you lose by 2% 3% like
bado did in Texas he lost
do you remember John Asaf no of course
you don't John Asaf was the old beta
O'Rourke John aasif was this guy that
they were running I think in the
Georgia's sixth congressional district
Newt Gingrich is old seed he was running
then in also in Tom prices old seat when
Tom Price was appointed by the Trump
administration to run Health and Human
Services and this was going to be the
big the first referendum on Trump and
the Democrats are gonna win they poured
millions millions tens of millions of
dollars into this race and he lost same
thing the media sort of treated him like
a winner they said oh it was a moral
victory oh he came close and then he's
done he's over he's not going anywhere
and I think bado is gonna have to deal
with that now unfortunately for him
baito has one play left
Beto's only play is that he needs to
convince Iowa voters that he can win
Texas in a general election
how many electoral votes does Texas have
32 or more electoral 38 or something
that's a lot of electoral votes you win
Texas as a Democrat the election doesn't
matter what else happens you win the
election so what what beta or work is
gonna try to do is say listen Iowa
voters you might not like me I might be
a loser I might be creepy and weird
I might dress up like a furry I might
wear dresses in my band and I might
skateboard around Whataburger parking
lots but I can bring you Texas that's a
long shot because that's a really
unsatisfying political message if you're
only campaigning on some crass political
message I'll do really well in this
state you're not inspiring people you're
not getting people out to the polls also
it's just not true the bado isn't gonna
win Texas against Donald Trump
it's not gonna happen he was going up
against Ted Cruz in a an election where
I love Ted Cruz I think he's a great guy
he's not the best retail politician in
the country and he was going in damaged
from the primary campaign against Donald
Trump's he had some Republicans some
Trump voters who didn't like Ted Cruz
going into that election that ain't
gonna happen in a presidential year so
the even the case if bado could make it
is pretty weak I think he's probably
done I think Budaj edges eating his
lunch and Budaj edge also very unlikely
to be the Democrat nominee but he might
have a better play for Vice President
before we go I have to talk about this
this issue in the United Kingdom because
we're talking here broadly I guess about
these these two strategies that the left
and the right entertain you've got the
left
pushing fantasy and relying on ignorance
and you've got the right pushing history
and relying on education relying on
knowledge probably Democrats in speaking
in electoral politics Democrats have the
easier chance it's always easier to bet
on ignorant and to push fantasy than it
is to rely on reality and people's
knowledge of reality when you're talking
about democratic politics but there's
this case right now in the United
Kingdom it shows this difference between
reality and fantasies so clearly there
is parents in the UK who transitioned
their seven-year-old biological son into
pretending that he's a girl
seven-year-old kid he either decides
he's a girl or his parents tell him that
he's a girl then he starts dressing him
up they start dressing him up like a
girl okay that's bad but who knows
families are in weird
who knows maybe there's something here
we don't know about then these parents
transitioned a three-year-old foster
child in their care into pretending that
he's a girl not
logical child a foster child now it's
come out that a third child that they
fostered also suffered gender issues if
it were just one child I'd say look
they're bad parents for indulging in
this delusion but maybe the kid really
does have this condition maybe the kid
really does have gender dysphoria and he
really is is just uncomfortable with his
biological sex we know that about 0.2 or
0.3 percent of the population suffers
from gender confusion so maybe it's
their kid who has it now what are the
odds let's say these parents have two
biological kids what are the odds that
both of their kids would have gender
dysphoria infinitesimally low but you
might say well it's biological so maybe
it's just something in the genes that
gives but the kids in this family gender
confusion what are the odds that if they
had three biological kids they would all
have it again so infinitesimally low but
again you could say well it's in the
genes it's it maybe it's in the genes
okay but only one of the kids was
biological the other two were foster
kids completely different genes the only
thing in common was how they were raised
the only thing in common were these sick
parents who should never be allowed to
be anywhere near children because
obviously it is the parents pushing this
sick ideology on them that causes poor
little helpless boys a three-year-old
boy to think that he's in some way a
girl sending him to school in dresses
and the school asked the parents they
said please stop sending your son in
dresses the parent said no we're gonna
do it these sickos these perverts these
child abusers obviously there's nothing
biological here the second kid in the
third kid are not biologically related
to these parents and yet they all have
gender confusion guess how a UK judge
ruled in the question of
these were fit parents the judge said no
it's totally okay nothing wrong here
nothing to see here and actually if you
question whether this little boy is
actually a little girl you you're the
bigot you're the racist you're the trans
homophobic whatever made-up word they
have because fantasy is winning in our
in our governing class in our political
class and our politically correct class
in our media class fantasy is winning
historical fantasy biological fantasy
legal fantasy is all winning right now
now I think the people realize this
isn't true I think that's how you get
elections like the election of Donald
Trump the the brexit election you get
this popular revulsion at the gender
ideology being pushed on us by the left
but that is a battle and it's a it's a
an example clear as day between people
who have some react relation to reality
and those self-appointed elites who want
to tell us reality is not as it is
that's that's going to be a defining
overwhelming feature not just of the
2020 election but our politics for the
foreseeable future we'll see how it
plays out we got a lot more to get to
but you know hey we always run late come
back tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy Borah senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Joshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 hey everyone I'm Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know daniel patrick moynihan once
famously said everyone is entitled to
his own opinion but not to his own facts
the Democrats have been living off their
own facts for a while now and they've
built themselves a protective wall made
of the press in the entertainment
industry and the Academy to keep those
facts safe well now the real facts are
building up outside the wall like the
zombies in World War Z outside the walls
of Jerusalem it's not going to be pretty
that's on the Andrew Klavan show I'm
Andrew Clavin